yes okay so back to poincare so
um he's you know it's funny this book is
filled with kind of
you know mathematical characters who
often are kind of
peevish or get into feuds or sort of
have like
weird enthusiasms um because those
people are fun to write about and they
sort of like say
very salty things poincare is actually
none of this as far as i can tell
he was an extremely normal dude he
didn't get into fights with people
and everybody liked him and he was like
pretty personally modest and he had
very regular habits you know what i mean
he did math for like
four hours in the morning and four hours
in the evening and that was it like he
had his
schedule um i actually i was like i
still am feeling like
somebody's going to tell me now the book
is out like oh didn't you know about
this like incredibly sorted episode
as far as i could tell uh a completely
normal guy but
um he just kind of in many ways
creates uh the geometric world in which
we live and and you know
his first really big success uh is this
prize paper he writes for this prize
offered by the king of sweden
for the study of the three-body problem
um
the study of what we can say about yeah
three
astronomical objects moving and what you
might think would be this very simple
way nothing's going on except
gravity uh releasing the three-body
problem why is it a problem
so the problem is to understand um when
this motion is stable and when it's not
so stable meaning they would sort of
like end up in some kind of periodic
orbit or i guess it would mean sorry
stable would mean they never sort of fly
off far apart from each other
and unstable would mean like eventually
they fly apart so understanding two
bodies is
much easier yeah third uh
two bodies this is what newton knew two
bodies they sort of orbit each other and
some kind of uh
either in an ellipse which is the stable
case you know that's what the planets
do that we know um or uh
one travels on a hyperbola around the
other that's the unstable case it sort
of like zooms in from far away sort of
like whips around the
heavier thing and like zooms out um
those are basically the two options so
it's a very simple and easy to classify
story
with three bodies just the small switch
from two to three uh
it's a complete zoo it's the first exam
what we would say now is it's the first
example of what's called chaotic
dynamics
where the stable solutions and the
unstable solutions they're kind of like
wound in among each other and a very
very very tiny change in the initial
conditions can
make the long-term behavior of the
system completely different so poincare
was the first to recognize that that
phenomenon even
uh even existed what about the uh
conjecture that carries his name right
so
he also um
was one of the pioneers of taking
geometry um which until that point
had been largely the study of two and
three-dimensional objects because that's
like
what we see right that's those are the
odd strings we interact with
um he developed that subject we now
called topology he called it
analysis situs he was a very well-spoken
guy with a lot of slogans but
that name did not you can see why that
name did not catch on so now
it's called topology now um
sorry what was it called before analysis
situs
which i guess sort of roughly means like
the analysis of location or something
like that
like um it's a latin phrase
um partly because he understood
that even to understand stuff that's
going on
in our physical world you have to study
higher dimensional spaces
how does this how does this work and
this is kind of like where my brain went
to it because you were talking about
not just where things are but what their
path is how they're moving when we were
talking about the path from two to three
um he understood that if you want to
study three to three bodies
moving in space well each
uh each body it has a location where it
is so it has an
x coordinate a y coordinate and a z
coordinate right i can specify a point
in space by giving you three numbers
but it also at each moment has a
velocity
so it turns out that really to
understand what's going on
you can't think of it as a point or you
could but it's
better not to think of it as a point in
three-dimensional space that's moving
it's better to think of it as a point in
six-dimensional space where the
coordinates are where is it
and what's its velocity right now that's
a higher dimensional space called
phase space and if you haven't thought
about this before i admit that it's a
little bit
mind-bending but
what he needed then was a geometry that
was flexible enough
not just to talk about two-dimensional
spaces or three-dimensional spaces but
any dimensional space so the sort of
famous first line of this paper where he
introduces analysis
is is no one doubts nowadays that the
geometry of
n-dimensional space is an actually
existing thing right i think that
maybe that had been controversial and
he's saying like look let's face it just
because it's not physical
doesn't mean it's not there it doesn't
mean we shouldn't it's
interesting he wasn't jumping to the
physical the physical interpretation
like it does
it can be real even if it's not
perceivable to
human cognition i think i think that's
right i think
don't get me wrong poincare never strays
far from physics he's always motivated
by physics
but the physics drove him to need to
think about spaces of higher dimension
and so he needed a formalism that was
rich enough to enable him to do that and
once you do that that formalism is also
going to include things that are not
physical
and then you have two choices you can be
like oh well that stuff's trash
or but i think and this is more the
mathematicians frame of mind
if you have a formalistic framework that
like seems really good and sort of seems
to be like very elegant and work well
and it includes all the physical stuff
maybe we should think about all of it
like maybe we should think about it
think you know maybe there's some gold
to be mined there
and indeed like you know guess what like
before long there's relativity and
there's space time and like all of a
sudden it's like oh yeah maybe it's a
good idea we already have this geometric
apparatus like set up for like how to
think about
four-dimensional spaces like turns out
they're real after all
you know this is a a story much told
right in mathematics not just in this
context but in many i'd love to dig in a
little deeper on that actually because
i have some uh intuitions to work out
okay my brain well i'm not a
mathematical physicist so we can work
them out together
good we'll uh we'll we'll together walk
along the path of curiosity
but pancreatic uh conjecture
what is it the point conjecture is about
curved
three-dimensional spaces so i was on my
way there i promise
um the idea is that we perceive
ourselves as living
in we don't say a three-dimensional
space we just say three-dimensional
space you know you can go
up and down you can go left and right
you can go forward and back there's
three dimensions in which you can move
in poincare's theory there are many
possible three-dimensional spaces
in the same way that going down one
dimension to sort of
capture our intuition a little bit more
we know there are lots of different
two-dimensional surfaces right there's
a balloon and that looks one way and a
donut looks another way and a mobius
strip
looks a third way those are all like
two-dimensional surfaces that we can
kind of really uh
get a global view of because we live in
three-dimensional space so we can see a
two-dimensional surface sort of sitting
in our three-dimensional space well to
see a three-dimensional space
whole we'd have to kind of have
four-dimensional eyes right which we
don't so we have to use our mathematical
eyes we have to envision
um the poincare conjecture
uh says that there's a very simple way
to determine whether a three-dimensional
space
um is the standard one the one that
we're used to
um and essentially it's that it's what's
called fundamental group
has nothing interesting in it and not
that i can actually say without saying
what the fundamental group is i can tell
you what the criterion is
this would be oh look i can even use a
visual aid so for the people watching
this on youtube you'll just see this for
the people
uh on the podcast you'll have to
visualize it so lex has been nice enough
to like
give me a surface with some interesting
topology it's a mug right here in front
of me
a mug yes i might say it's a genus one
surface but we could also say it's a mug
same thing
um so if i were to draw
a little circle on this mug oh which way
should i draw it so it's visible like
here
okay yeah if i draw a little circle on
this mug imagine this to be a loop of
string
i could pull that loop of string closed
on the surface of
the mug right that's definitely
something i could do i could shrink it
shrink it shrink it until it's a point
on the other hand if i draw a loop that
goes around the handle
i can kind of judge it up here and i can
judge it down there and i can sort of
slide it up and down the handle but i
can't pull it closed can't i it's
trapped
not without breaking the surface of the
mug right not without like going inside
so um the condition of being what's
called simply connected this is
one of funko ray's inventions says that
any loop of string can be pulled shut
so it's a feature that the mug simply
does not have this is a non-simply
connected mug and a simply connected mug
would be a cup
right you would burn your hand when you
drink coffee out of it so you're saying
the universe is not a mug
well i can't speak to the universe but
what i can say is that
um regular old space
is not a mug regular old space if you
like sort of actually physically have
like a loop of string
you can always close your shot you're
going to pull a [ __ ]
but you know what if your piece of
string was the size of the universe like
what if your poi
your piece of string was like billions
of light years long like like how do you
actually know
i mean that's still an open question of
the shape of the universe exactly
whether it's uh i think there's a lot
there is
ideas of it being a tourist i mean
there's there's some trippy ideas and
they're not
like weird out there controversial
there's a legitimate
at the center of uh cosmology debate
i mean i think i think with somebody who
thinks that there's like some kind of
dodecahedral symmetry or i mean i
remember reading something crazy about
somebody saying that they saw the
signature of that and the
cosmic noise or what have you i mean to
make the flat earthers happy i do
believe that the current
main belief is it's fl
it's flat it's flat-ish or something
like that
the shape of the universe is flat-ish i
don't know what the heck that means i
think that
i think that has like a very i mean how
are you even supposed to
think about the shape of a thing
that doesn't have anything outside of it
i mean
ah but that's exactly what topology does
topology is what's called an intrinsic
theory
that's what's so great about it this
question about the mug
you could answer it without ever leaving
the mug
right because it's a question about a
loop drawn on the surface of the mug and
what happens if it never leaves that
surface so it's like
always there see but that's the the
difference between
then topology and say if you're like
uh trying to visualize a mug
that you can't visualize a mug while
living inside the mug
well that's true that visualization is
harder but in some sense no you're right
but if the tools of mathematics are
there
i i i don't want to fight but i think
the tools and mathematics are exactly
there to enable you to think about what
you cannot visualize in this way
let me give let's go always to make
things easier go downward dimension
let's think about we live on a circle
okay you can tell
whether you live on a circle or a line
segment
because if you live in a circle if you
walk a long way in one direction you
find yourself back where you started and
if you live in a line segment
you walk for a long enough one direction
you come to the end of the world or
if you live on a line like a whole line
an infinite line then you
walk in one direction for a long time
and like well then there's not a sort of
terminating algorithm to figure out
whether you live on a line or a circle
but at least you sort of
um at least you don't discover that you
live on a circle
so all of those are intrinsic things
right all of those are things that you
can figure out about your world without
leaving
your world on the other hand ready now
we're going to go from intrinsic to
extrinsic why did i not know we were
going to talk about this but why not
why not if you can't tell whether you
live in a circle
or a knot like imagine like a knot
floating in three-dimensional space the
person who lives on that knot to them
it's a circle
yeah they walk a long way they come back
to where they started now we with our
three-dimensional eyes can be like
oh this one's just a plain circle and
this one's knotted up but that's an
that's a that has to do with how they
sit in three-dimensional space it
doesn't have to do with intrinsic
features of those people's world
we can ask you one ape to another does
it make you
how does it make you feel that you don't
know if you live in a circle
or on a knot in a knot
in inside the string that forms the knot
i'm gonna even know how to say that i'm
gonna be honest with you i don't know if
i
i i i fear you won't like this answer
but it
does not bother me at all it does i
don't lose one minute of sleep over it
so like does it bother you that if we
look at like a mobius strip
that you don't have an obvious way of
knowing
whether you are inside of cylinder if
you live on a surface of a cylinder
or you live on the surface of a mobius
strip
no i think you can tell if you live if
which one because
if what you do is you like tell your
friend hey stay right here i'm just to
go for a walk and then
you like walk for a long time in one
direction and then you come back and you
see your friend again and if your friend
is reversed then you know you live on a
mobius trip well
no because you won't see your friend
right okay
fair fair point fair point on that and
wait
you have to believe the story is about
no i don't even know
i i i would would you even know would
you
really oh no you're i know your point is
right let me try to think of it better
let's see if i can do this on the floor
it may not be correct to talk about
cognitive beings living on a mobius
strip because
there's a lot of things taken for
granted there and we're constantly
imagining
actual like three-dimensional creatures
like
how it actually feels like to uh
to live on a mobius strip is tricky to
internalize
i think that on what's called the real
protective plane which is kind of even
more sort of like messed up version of
the
mobius strip but with very similar
features this feature of kind of like
only having one side that has the
feature that there's a loop of string
which can't be pulled closed but if you
loop
it around twice along the same path that
you can pull closed
that's extremely weird yeah um
but that would be a way you could know
without leaving your world that
something very funny is going on you
know what's extremely weird
maybe we can comment on hopefully it's
not too much of a tangent
is i remember thinking about this
this might be right this might be wrong
but if you're
if we now talk about a sphere
and you're living inside a sphere
that you're going to see everywhere
around you the back of your own head
that i was because like i was
this was very counterintuitive to me to
think about maybe it's wrong
but because i was thinking like earth
you know you're 3d
thing on sitting on a sphere but if
you're living inside the sphere
like you're going to see if you look
straight you're always going to see
yourself all the way around so
everywhere you look there's going to be
the back of your
head i think somehow this depends on
something of like how the physics of
light works in this scenario which i'm
sort of finding it hard to bend my
that's true the c is doing a lot of like
saying you see something's doing a lot
of work
people have thought about this i mean
this this metaphor of like what if we're
like
little creatures in some sort of smaller
world like how could we apprehend what's
outside that metaphor just comes back
and back and actually i didn't even
realize like how frequent it is it comes
up in the book a lot
i know it from a book called flatland i
don't know if you ever read this when
you were
a kid an adult you know this this
sort of sort of comic novel from the
19th century about
an entire two-dimensional world
uh it's narrated by a square that's the
main character
and um the kind of strangeness that
befalls him when
you know one day he's in his house and
suddenly there's like a little circle
there and there with him
and then but then the circle like starts
getting bigger
and bigger and bigger and he's like what
the hell is going on it's like a horror
movie like for
two-dimensional people and of course
what's happening is that a sphere is
entering his world and as the sphere
kind of like
moves farther and farther into the plane
it's cross-section the part of it that
he can see
to him it looks like there's like this
kind of bizarre being that's like
getting larger and larger and larger
um until it's exactly sort of halfway
through and then they have this kind of
like philosophical argument where the
sphere is like i'm a sphere i'm from the
third dimension the square's like what
are you talking about there's no such
thing
and they have this kind of like sterile
argument where the square is not
able to kind of like follow the
mathematical reasoning of this fear
until the sphere just kind of grabs him
and like jerks him out of the plane
and pulls him up and it's like now like
now do you see like now do you see your
whole world that you didn't understand
before
you